sechs typische fehler
nummer
house oder hause
das haus
das ist ein haus
[Musik]
das ist ein großes haus
ich habe ein neues haus gekauft
jetzt bin ich in das neue haus gezogen
[Musik]
ich will nach hause gehen
ich gehe nach hause
[Musik]
ich fahre nach
gehen wir zu dir oder zu mir nach hause
ich bin zu hause
ich bin gern zu hause
nummer fünf unten runter oder unter
mein auto steht unten
ich habe meine tasche unten in meinem
auto vergessen
ich gehe nach unten und hole meine
tasche
ich gehe nach unten
ich gehe runter
jetzt bin ich unten
unter dem auto sitzt eine katze
die katze sitzt unter dem auto
nummer vier obenauf oder rauf
mein schlüssel ist oben
ich gehe nach oben
ich gehe raus
jetzt bin ich oben
auf dem auto sitzt eine katze
die katze sitzt auf dem auto
die k
sie sitzt auf dem auto nummer drei kleid
kleider klamotten oder kleidung
ich trage gerne modische kleidung
meine klamotten sind immer trendy meine
klamotten sind immer trendy
meine klamotten sind schon alt ich
brauche neue kleider
mein kleidungsstil ist modern und
sportlich
manchmal trage ich aber auch ein
elegantes kleid
im kleiderladen kaufe ich viele kleider
nummer zwei die rhoder dich mir oder
mich
er schenkt mir ein geschenk
ich freue mich
er fragt mich
er fragt mich ich antworte dir
ich antworte dir
ich liebe dich und du liebst mich
gehen wir zu dir oder zu mir nach hause
die musik gefällt mir
ich sehe dich und du siehst mich
du willst mir und ich winke dir
du willst mir und ich winke dir nummer
eins als oder wie
[Musik]
der elefant ist schwerer als das schwein
das pony ist gleich schwer wie das
schwein
das pony ist nicht schwerer als das
[Musik]
jana ist größer als alexa
jana ist gleich groß wie klar
jana ist nicht größer als klar
jana ist älter als alexa
jana ist gleich als wie alexa
jana ist nicht älter als claire
das flugzeug ist schneller als der
hubschrauber
der zug ist gleich schnell wie der
der zug ist nicht schneller als der
hubschrauber
ich bin anderer meinung als du
ich bin gleicher meinung wie du
ich bin nicht gleicher meinung
wie du
welche fehler macht ihr auch
schreibt es in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]